the world is getting hotter oppressive
heat now stretching coast to coast
canada the u.s cyprus india iraq and
kuwait have seen scorching temperatures
in the past week
but though the dangers of rising
temperatures are well documented less is
known about the knock-on effects of
keeping cool air conditioning is one of
the worst
consumers of electricity it heats up the
planet
at least seven percent of greenhouse gas
emissions come from cooling
and with temperatures likely to soar
this is only going to get worse
the more the earth warms the more people
need air conditioners
but the more of those we have the warmer
the world will be cooling saves lives
and facilitates education and economic
growth in the world's hottest countries
it also brings huge environmental risks
so how can we keep cool without warming
the planet
[Music]
yes quiet is the word for this new 1954
rca air conditioner
air conditioning and refrigeration
systems changed the world they fueled
economic expansion
transformed how food and medicines are
stored and transported and helped save
thousands of lives
but in doing so they've become a major
contributor to global warming
air conditioners are bad for the
environment in a couple of ways together
with electric fans they already account
for around 20 of the total electricity
used in buildings america is one of the
biggest culprits
the electricity it uses for air
conditioning is equivalent to the total
electricity consumption of the continent
of africa
the problem with air conditioners
guzzling so much electricity is that
much of the world's power grids are
still fired up by fossil fuels like coal
and so it contributes to the greenhouse
gas problem in a very big way
what's more most air conditioners and
fridges use man-made gases such as
hydrofluorocarbons or hfcs as a cooling
medium
these gases have a tendency to leak into
the atmosphere where they are thousands
of times more potent at trapping heat
than carbon dioxide
and demand for air conditioning is still
rising
a big reason is urbanization
as populations around the world come out
of poverty and into modest or middle
class lives one of the first things
people want to buy is an air conditioner
currently there are some 2 billion ac
units in use around the world
most across just a handful of countries
but in the tropics over 90 percent of
the 3 billion or so people who live
there have yet to buy an ac unit
as temperatures and wages rise demand
for ac is predicted to skyrocket
by 2050 around two-thirds of the world's
households could have air conditioning
which means without policy intervention
emissions are projected to rise by 90
percent above 2017 levels by the year
2050.
we have to find a better way a more
energy efficient and climate-friendly
way of cooling the earth's population or
else this is going to be real trouble in
future
the race is on to solve the cooling
conundrum with innovative new methods
being trialled from technology to make
air conditioners more efficient to
completely eradicating the need for hfcs
at all
one company developing a radical new
method for cooling
is a stanford university spin-out called
skycool
so today we're on a roof at a
supermarket and we're deploying skycool
technology with their refrigeration
system
so our technology works by using the sky
itself as a heat sink and so whether
it's sunny out or not day or night the
sky is very cold and what our technology
is able to do is use that
cold upper atmosphere to cool things on
the surface of the earth with no input
electricity
and so by orienting these panels towards
the sky they're able to send out more
heat than they take in from our
atmosphere
sounds well pretty cool but sky cool so
far has only been installed in a handful
of places despite having plans for more
innovation is fantastic but as with the
latest iphone the poorest people in the
world are not likely to get the latest
kit they'll be the least able to buy
those efficient innovative models that
are now coming out
nascent technology like this can't be
relied upon alone to provide affordable
cooling on a mass scale more solutions
are necessary
so there's a lot to be said for reducing
demand for mechanical cooling in the
first place through improved buildings
better urban design and nature-based
approaches
designing buildings so they don't need
air conditioning may be part of the
answer
after all that's how it was done before
ac was invented
pre-world war ii
buildings were designed to be passively
cooled they had windows that opened they
looked at ventilation and how it moved
through the building and our standards
of comfort were a little different
between 1946 and 1955 nearly 1.5 million
homes were constructed every year in
america
this building boom brought about cooling
complications
post world war ii we see this explosion
in the use of air conditioning in
buildings the race for skyscrapers takes
over who can be the tallest who can be
the biggest it becomes a competition
we can't open the windows at those
higher heights so now these hermetically
sealed buildings require even more
cooling load
but today innovative building design is
providing solutions to keep buildings
cool without relying on air conditioning
this floating office in rotterdam which
houses the global center on adaptation
is a green architect's dream
it's powered off-grid
heated by solar panels cooled by the
river beneath it and made mostly from
wood so uh let's go inside and i'll show
you how it works
so here we are actually inside the
floating foundation of the floating
office
and what we see here is actually all
technology that we use to cool the
building
we use the concrete of the barges and we
do that by pumping cooling liquid
through pipes that are in the concrete
[Music]
the ceiling is a cooling ceiling so
through the ceiling actually there's the
same pipes that are also going through
the concrete
so the water is actually uh in these
pipes actually cooled by the concrete
and then it's actually being pumped
through the ceilings
the global center on adaptation is the
largest floating office in the world
but although its exact cost isn't known
it's rumored to have been expensive to
build
and with rotterdam's average summer
temperature only around 18 degrees
celsius
some might argue that keeping a building
cool in this climate isn't hard
projects like the global center on
adaptation are impressive and they're
great that they exist
if only for their standout technology
and their beautiful design
but what we need are scalable deployable
solutions that are affordable that we
can do everywhere
in cairo egypt where temperatures
regularly surpass 35 degrees celsius
the need for scalable and sustainable
cooling systems has never been more
urgent
the heat stress that we are facing is a
rear wake-up call
sarah albatuty and her company econsult
were recently awarded funding from
ashton a climate solutions charity for
their innovative cooling designs so you
can imagine how much material we now
have
she takes inspiration from traditional
cooling techniques that have been used
by communities for centuries
if you go to uh desert communities or
communities in rural cairo some you
you're astonished by the level of
cooling and um they do it by knowing
exactly the correct ratios to build how
thick the walls are
incorporating some of these age-old
techniques in the design of new
buildings can drastically reduce the
need for air conditioning
in order to avoid heat you don't go in
from desert to door immediately you walk
in into an entryway that is very dark
and it's cooler than the desert and then
the difference is three to four degrees
before you enter
a room inside from a building's
orientation to the use of local stone
that stays cool
drawing on local knowledge could help
more communities find sustainable and
scalable alternatives to air
conditioning
four and a half thousand miles south in
cape town south africa cheap adaptations
to existing buildings can also reduce
the need for ac
in one community roofs made of
corrugated iron heat up like an oven
during the summer months so they've
painted them white
the same way that on a hot day you might
wear a hat or on a hot day you might
wear white to reflect heat our buildings
can kind of do the same thing just by
putting a white reflective coating on
these roofs we can reflect most of that
heat and what it does is it'll not only
cool the building down
but cool the neighbors around it down as
well
that's because white roofs can reflect
sunlight better meaning the roof itself
can stay about 30 degrees celsius cooler
making the internal temperature
two to five degrees celsius less than a
building with a roof painted another
color like grey
green buildings cannot be high-end
because
extreme heat doesn't only affect people
on the high end and it affects everybody
in various different ways so there needs
to be
a building that caters to
this kind of solution for all income
stratas
while cheap improvements to walls roofs
and windows could reduce the energy
needed for cooling small-scale
initiatives don't go far enough
far-reaching policies and the
large-scale ambition to implement them
are what's needed to bring about change
some governments are responding to the
challenge
eleni miravilli was appointed europe's
first chief heat officer for athens in
2021
her job is to come up with sustainable
cooling solutions for all of the city
this summer was an extraordinary summer
in the sense that it started with a heat
wave in june we had these wildfires
taking place at the same time so not
only was it difficult to breathe the
skies were dark clouds were gray and red
it felt like a post-apocalyptic scene
from a movie
like many cities athens suffers from the
urban heat island effect due to trees
and plants being replaced with asphalt
and concrete which absorb and then
release heat into the air
here the average annual land surface
temperatures of urban areas can get up
to 3.8 degrees celsius hotter than
non-urban areas at midday
fellaini is trying to mitigate this by
turning some of the city streets into
pedestrianized tree-lined corridors
so when this is changed and it becomes a
pedestrian green corridor
somebody walking down the street will
have a different experience much more
thermal comfort as we say because it's
actually going to feel up to two or two
and a half degrees cooler than the rest
of the city
eleni's team plans to create three green
corridors across athens over the next
two years
and she plans to make the most of the
cooling greenery that's already there
we've been focusing on supporting the
existing green areas that we have the
existing urban forest parks and the
hills supporting the trees and making
sure that we have more of them and
actually replenish the nature that we
already have
multiple studies have shown that
increasing green areas in cities is
crucial to reduce temperatures and the
need for air conditioning if we can
create more efficient ways of cooling
we'll be able to bring down emissions
linked to buildings as well as those
from air conditioners
the work that athens is doing in
thinking about cooling the city
is very powerful and needs to be
replicated in other places the urban
heat island effect is a serious
phenomenon it's only going to get worse
and it's most likely to affect
disadvantaged communities the most
a number of cities are making
adaptations like athens
paris plans to have 50 of the city
covered by planted areas by 2030.
medellin in colombia has already won
awards for its green corridors
and emdabad in india has been
acknowledged for its heat action plan
the first of its kind in south asia
we have to think of solutions that are
sustainable and that are resilient and
this means that we have to think of
cooling the whole city so that the
building is cooler so that we don't need
so much heating and cooling by using
fossil fuel dependent appliances and
this is extremely important because if
we continue like this again we're gonna
see just higher temperatures and higher
temperatures and more crazy climate
phenomena
[Music]
to implement the city-wide and
ultimately country-wide solutions needed
to cool the planet sustainably will
require cooperation on an unprecedented
scale
this is going to require industry
government finance and civil society to
work together we both have to deploy the
most efficient technologies existing as
well as invent new technologies so that
we have an opportunity for the
developing world to leapfrog ahead to a
cooler and brighter future
[Music]
i'm vijay vadis warren the economist
global energy and climate innovation
editor
to keep up to date with all of our
climate change coverage
please click on the link
thanks for watching and don't forget to
subscribe
you